اتفاقات وقف اطلاق النار لا تعمر طويلا في
حرب كارباخ هذا ما يتضح من مصير ل تجربتين
لوقف القتال في غضون ايام معدوده سعت
اليهما روسيا بالتنسيق مع ارمينيا
واذربيجان لكن سرعان ما نسفت هما وقائع
الميدان كعادتها مازالت اطراف الصراع
تتراشق بالاتهامات بانتهاك اتفاق وقف
اطلاق النار المعلن لاغراض انسانيه فما
مصير الهدنه الهشه الجديده وكيف لروسيا ان
تحمل الارمنيين والاذربيجانية
ز ماتهم وهل يعود الفشل في الامتثال
للاتفاقات الى حاله العداء المستحكم بين
الطرفين ام الى غياب اراده جاده وضغوط
قويه من اجل تهدئه توقف شلال
[موسيقى]
الدماء يشيع الاذربيجاني قتلاهم وقد قضوا
في قصف صاروخي استهدف مدينه جانجا انها
مجزره تقول باكو بل جريمه حرب كان وقودها
مدنيون قتل منهم 12 وجرح عشرات حصيله قتله
هي من بين الاعلى منذ نشوب القتال بين
الجانبين وهو ما دفع الرئيس الاذربيجاني
الى التهديد بالرد على ان يكون باستعاده
مزيد من الاراضي الاذربيجانيه في كارباخ
حتى استعادته كاملا كما قال حدث هذا قبل
ساعات ثقيله ومشحونه بالتوتر انتهت بهدنيه
انسانيه جديده بعد تلك التي وصلت اليها
موسكو قبل نحو اسبوع وحسب وزير الخارجيه
الروسي فانه يجب على الطرفين الالتزام
الصارم بوقف اطلاق النار والبدء بمفاوضات
بناءه على اساس المبادئ الرئيسيه لمجموعه
منسك لتسويه النزاع في كارباخ لكن الهدنه
الجديده سرعان من انهارت كسابقتها وقالت
وزاره الدفاع الاذربيجانيه ان ارمينيا لم
تمتثل للهدنه وقصفت مواقع في اقدارا وفز
وهدرت وجبرائيل بينما تعرضت عده قر في
محيط مدينه ترتار لقصف ارميني عنيف تنفي
ريفان ذلك وتقول ان اذربيجان هي التي خرقت
الهدنه واستان هجومها في الجبهه
الجنوبيه وياتي هذا بعد زياره الرئيس
الارميني لقواته وتشديده في الوقت نفسه
على البحث عن حل سلمي للصراع وهو ما تقول
باكو انه لن يتحقق الا بعوده الاقليم
كاملا الى السياده
الاذربيجانيه وحسب مراقبين فان ارمينيا
تسعى الى توازن رعب في الميدان وداخل
الاراضي الاذربيجانيه نفسها لكبح تقدم
باكو ميدانيا في كارباخ وتحسين وضعها
التفاوضي وربما يفسر ذلك لجوءها الى قصف
صاروخي توعدت باكو بالرد عليه داخل
الاراضي الارمينيه مثل ما فعلت قبل ايام
بقصفها منصات صواريخ داخل ارمينيا وتعهدت
وزاره الدفاع الاذربيجانيه بتدمير جميع
المنشات العسكريه الارمينيه التي تستهدف
موا مدنيه اذربيجانيه وردت يرفان بانها
ستستهدف بدورها اي بنيه تحتيه او تجهيزات
عسكريه داخل اراضي اذربيجان ما يعني ان
جغرافيا الصراع تتوسع وانها مرشحه لمزيد
من الاتساع ليشمل مسرحها اراضي ومدنا في
البلدين ما لم يلتزم بوقف اطلاق النار
بشكل
صارم متابعه للتطورات الميدانيه ينضم
الينا من مدينه منج شيفير بمحيط كارباخ من
الجانب الاذربيجاني مراسل الجزيره المعتز
بالله حسن وكذلك من مدينه جوريس في محيط
كارباخ من الجانب الارميني مراسل الجزيره
محمود الزيبق وابدا معك محمود الزيبق وبعد
مرور قرابه اليوم او 44 ساعه على ابرام
هذه الهدنه الثانيه كيف تبدو الاوضاع على
الارض والى اي حد هناك التزام
بها حقيقه ايمان خلال جولتنا اليوم داخل
اقليم كارباخ ربما نستطيع ان نقول ان
الوضع قبل الهدنه كان ربما اهدا من الوضع
بعد الهدنه
حقيقه الاصوات الانفجارات اصوات القذائف
المدفعيه الطائرات بدون طيار كلها كانت
تشي بان الوضع ربما هو اسوا
وليس يعني الهدنه ليس لها على الارض مكان
دعيني انقل لك ايمان تصريحات صدرت قبل
قليل عن وزاره الدفاع الارمينيه فيما
يتعلق بالمعارك على الارض قالت فيها وهي
تصريحات ربما جديده في هذا النوع قالت
فيها ان
اذربيجان حققت او سجلت بعض التحرك في
الجبهه في القطاع الجنوبي
للمعارك هذا التصريح طبعا واضاف المتحدث
باسم وزاره الدفاع ان هذه حرب طبعا استدرك
ان هذه حرب من الجيل الخامس وانه لا يمكن
ان التاكيد على يعني ان خطوه الى الامام
او خطوه الى الوراء لن تكون ذات اهميه
كبيره في حرب من الجيل الخامس كما وصف
كذلك تحدث عن معارك في الجبهه الشماليه
وقال ان القوات الاذ الاذربيجانيه لم تحقق
نجاحا كبيرا هناك كذلك في في في منطقه
اخرى في الجبهه الجنوبيه قال انهم كبدو
الاذربيجاني خسائر كبيره في العتاد
والجنود في نفس الوقت اليوم تحدثوا ايضا
عن
اي اسقاط تس تسعه طائرات اثنين منها في
الاراضي الارمينيه تسعه طائرات طبعا بدون
طيار نحن انا كمراسل موجود في الاراضي
الارمينيه المتاخمه لاقليم كارباخ وكنا في
اقليم كارباخ ايضا اليوم استطيع ان اؤكد
ان هناك طائرات بدون طيار كانت في الاجواء
لكن طبعا بالتاكيد نحن كمراسلين لا نستطيع
تحديد هويه هذه الطائرات دون طيار لكن
بالعموم ايمان وضع الهدنه يبدو وضعا هشا
ويبدو ان هناك تصريحات سياسيه قد تتجه الى
التصعيد اكثر منها تصريحات رئيس الوزراء
لمصادر اعلاميه رئيس الوزراء الارميني
الذي قال انها ان ان الحل الوحيد قد يكون
هو الاعتراف
باستقلال اقليم كارباخ وهو ما قد يكون
تصعيدا كبيرا للموقف وربما تصعيدا كبيرا
ايضا للمعارك التي ما زالت فعليا كما
شاهدنا اليوم في كارباخ مشتعله وربما اكثر
من السابق على ج جميع الجبهات ابقى معنا
محمود
الزيبق اتحول الان الى مراسلنا على الجانب
الاذربيجاني من الاقليم معنا من هناك
المعتز بالله حسن اذا يعني تحدث محمود عن
ان هذه الاوضاع ربما كانت اهدا قبل ابرام
هذه الاتفاقات او هذا هذه الهدنه من بعدها
وان
الوضع على الارض ربما يتجه الى التصعيد
اكثر ماذا عنه على الجانب حيث انت ا
المعتز بالتاكيد ايمان منذ الصباح الباكر
صدر بيان عن وزاره الدفاع الاذربيجانيه
قالت فيه ان ارمينيا استهدفت عده نقاط
للجيش الاذربيجاني في عده مناطق على طول
خط الجبهه مع اقليم كارباخ هذه المناطق من
بينها فيزولي ومن بينها ايضا جبرائيل
وغيرها من المواقع التي بات يتموضع فيها
الجيش الاذربيجاني خلال العمليات العسكريه
التي قام بها خلال الايام الماضيه حتى نضع
مشاهدينا الاعزاء في ضوء الخارطه
الجغرافيه اقليم كارباخ يحيط به سبعه مدن
واسعه هذه المدن وهذه المدن السبعه مع
اقليم كارباخ تقول اذربيجان ان ارمينيا
تحتلها والتواجد الارميني في هذه المناطق
يعود الى الحرب التي كانت منذ 7 عاما الى
28 عاما الجيش الاذربيجاني في الايام
الاخيره استطاع ك ما يقول تحرير فيزولي
وجبرائيل اليوم كان هناك عده رسائل رمزيه
من الجانب الاذربيجاني اذ رفع العلم
الاذربيجاني في منتصف مدينه فيزولي التي
اعلن الرئيس الاذربيجاني عن تحريرها امس
من مما سماه الاحتلال الارميني ايضا كان
هناك رساله رمزيه اخرى برفع العلم
الاذربيجاني على جسر خدا فيرين هذا الجسر
الذي يصل جبرائيل مع الاراضي الايرانيه
فوق نهر ال فوق نهر اراز كل ذلك هو ضمن
الاطار الذي اعلنت عنه اذربيجان انها
ماضيه في تحرير اراضيها من الاحتلال
الارميني وفق تسميه الاذربيجانيه وانها
تقول انها تريد هذه الاراضي اراضيها ان
تستعيدها سواء بالحرب او
بالمفاوضات الهدنه التيان كانت انسانيه
المعتز ابدا ايمان منذ منذ الصباح الباكر
نحن شهود على ذلك كان هناك اصوات سقوط
قذائف على الجانب الاذربيجاني وكان هناك
اطلاق نيران من هنا بالاتجاه الاخر اي ان
الهدنه الهدنه الانسانيه وحالها كحال
الهدنه السابقه ليست موجوده على الارض
اشكرك اذا المعتز بالله حسن كنت معنا من
محيط كارباخ على الجانب الاذربيجاني وشكرا
لك محمود الزيبق مراسل الجزيره كنت معنا
من الجانب
الارميني لمناقشه اوسع ينضم الينا من
يرفان الكاتب الصحفي ساكو اريان ومعنا من
باكو ايميل عبد اللطيف استاذ العلاقات
الدوليه بجامعه باكو وكذلك معنا من موسكو
اندريه ايكوف الكاتب والمحلل السياسي اهلا
بكم جميعا وابدا مع ابدا معك عفوا سيد
ساكو اريان اذا يعني هدنه ثانيه على ما
يبدو بعد فشل اولى قبل اسبوع هناك بوادر
على ربما فشلها او انهيارها
بين الجانبين ما اسباب ذلك وقد استمعت
معنا الى كلا المراسلين على الجانبين
يقولان بان الاوضاع الان اكثر سوء مما
كانت
قبلها لصراحه لم اسمع للصحفيين انا اسف
كنت متاخرا ولكن اريد ان اقول ان هذا وقف
اطلاق النار الثاني بعد ع تسعه ايام تماما
اي بعد الاتفاق في موسكو وال الطرف
الازاري بدا بالنار واليوم ايضا نرى نفس
السيناريو يتكرر لماذا يتكرر لان الطرف
الازاري مره واثنان وثلاثه واربعه ربما
عشر محاولات لوقف اطلاق النار لن يرضى هو
يريد تغيير ارض الواقع بالاساليب العسكريه
بالغطس
بالمرتزقه الاتين من سوريا طبعا
بالاختصاصيين الاتراك ايضا الموجودون في
ارض المعركه يعني هذا اسلوبهم هذا مرفوض
من من جميع دول العالم اليوم نحن راينا
ايضا وفد رسمي الماني بعد الوفد الروسي
اليوم في العاصمه ستيبان جيرت وهم ايضا
يندد بهذه الطريقه بهذه
الغطرسه قالوها بالفم الملان ان الطرف
الازاري يعني يفعل اباده بدرون هذه عباره
مصطلح جديد وعده خبراء امريكيين عسكريين
يعني قالوا ايضا ان اذربيجان تستعمل كل
الوسائل العسكريه المحرمه دوليا وهي تقود
حرب جيل خامس ارمينيا اليوم تحارب سيدتي
ليس فقط اذربيجان وايضا انقره والمرتزقه
تضل في المقابل بيان الدفاع الاذربيجانيه
يقول بان ارمينيا هي من تخرق بشكل فاضح
وقد تواصلت يعني هجماتها وقصفها اليوم على
طول الجبهات يعني حتى وان خرق احد الطرفين
ماذا عن الطرف الاخر هل يعني لماذا لا
يلتزم وان كانت هذه الهدنه انسانيه خصوصا
لتبادل الاسرى وربما ساحب الجنود من
القتلى والجرحى بين
الطرفين اريد ان اشير كما قلت الوضع
الانساني سيء جدا يعني عشرات القتلى لم
يدفنوا من الطرفين يعني هذا محرم دينيا
اسلاميا ومس مسيحيا وبكل الديانات
العالميه يعني التي تؤ تؤمن بحقوق الانسان
ولكن الطرف الارميني يجب ان يدافع عن نفسه
جيش الدفاع كارباخ يعني اسمه على مسمى
دفاع عن النفس دفاع عن الارض ودفاع عن
العرض هذا هذا هو المبدا الارميني
وارمينيا لن تتفرج يعني جيش ارتساخ لن
يتفرج ابدا
لعمليات العدو الزيري وايضا محاوله خلط
الاوراق على ارض الواقع سيده سيد اميل عبد
اللطيف يعني الخارجيه الارمينيه تتحدث عن
او تقول ان
اذربيجان تتنكر لما تضمنه هذا الاتفاق
اتفاق الهدنه من من بنود وتقف امام
تنفيذ بنوده ال ال الانسانيه ما الذي يحول
دون ذلك وقد يعني ذكرت سابقا بانها
انسانيه مساء الخير وشكرا جزيلا على هذه
الاستضافه في البدايه اود ان اقول ان
اذربيجان ليست من يخرق وقف اطلاق النار
عندما تم الاتفاق على اول هدنه في العاشر
من اكتوبر كل العالم شاهد ما قامت به
ارمينيا قصفت غنجه وغنج ليست موجوده من
ضمن اراضي النزاع وهي بعيده عن منطقه
النزاع وكل وسائل الاعلام وكل ممثلي
البعثات الدبلوماسيه بالاضافه الى كل
المنظمات
الدوليه الموجوده كان باستطاعتها ان تشاهد
ما حصل في غنجه كان هناك اهداف مدنيه
وقتلوا عددا كبيرا من الناس في جنجه
والامر سيان ليله امس ويمكن التحقق من ذلك
ان ارمينيا هي الجهه التي تخرق وقف اطلاق
النار من جهه هي خرق وقف اطلاق النار ومن
ناحيه اخرى تود ارمينيا ان تستخدم هذه
المظله لكي تحصل على
الاسلحه الان عن هذه الهدنه
الثانيه سيد اميل عبد اللطيف نتحدث عن
هدنه ثاني على ما يبدو يعني هناك بوادر
على ايضا فشلها وعدم صمودها كيف كيف يمكن
ان تتعامل معها اذربيجان الان وان كانت
ارمينيا هي التي تخرق حسب
قولكم
نعم ان ارمينيا تخرق هذه الهدنه من خلال
استهداف الاهداف المدنيه في غنجه والمناطق
الاخرى التي استهدفت بين ليله امس واليوم
وكلها اخبار يمكن التحقق منها من خلال
وسائل الاعلام والصحفيين في الميدان ما
تحاول هي ايضا تخرق في
المقابل
ان اذربيجان ترد على الخروقات من الجانب
الارميني لان ارمينيا تحاول ان تستفز
اذربيجان ولكن الرئيس ليله امس تحدث الى
المواطنين في البلد وقال لهم اننا لا
نستهدف المدنيين على سبيل المثال كان
باستطاعتنا ان ننتقل بسرعه الى الامام في
هذه الحرب ولكن هدف القوات الاذربيجانيه
لا تستهدف المدنيين ما يبطئ التقدم ولكن
هذا على عكس ما يحصل من الجانب الاخر نحن
ناخذ الحطه والحذر بالنسبه الى المدنيين
موجودين في ناغورنو كارباخ ولكن ولسوء
الحظ القوات الارمينيه وال ايضا ما يسمى
بقوات الدفاع عن ناغورنو كارباخ يستخدمون
المدنيين كدروع بشريه وهحول اليك في روسيا
سيد انتيكوف يعني استمعت معنا الى
الجانبين مازال هناك اتهامات واتهامات
متبادله وهي ها هي يعني الهدنه الاولى قد
فشلت ويبدو على ان الهدنه الثانيه ستلقى
المصير نفسه ما الذي يعنيه ذلك لموسكو
طبعا هذا تطور مغلق للغايه ونحن نشاهد
استمرار الاقتتال وحتى الخبراء في ارمينيا
واذربيجان
يتهمون البعض البعض
يطهون نعم البعض البعض وهذا ينص على ان
ربما انا اعتقد بري شخصي وبرغم من الجهود
الروسيه طبعا وروسيا هي الوحيده التي
حقيقه تطل تلك الجهود على الارض وليس فقط
ت تضلي بتصريحات بالرغم من تلك الجهود نحن
يجب ان نعترف بان كلا طرفين بايرادات هما
استمرار هذا الاقتتال لماذا لان اولا
الطرف
الاذربيجاني قد حققت او حقق بعض الانجازات
على الارض هذا الشيء فتشعر ب
ب يعني تلك الانتصارات وايضا هناك التشجيع
من قبل الجانب التركي واضح وعلني تماما
تجاه باكو وايضا هناك دعم ضمني لاذربيجان
من تركيا فهذا ما يؤدي الى استمرار
الاقتتال من طرف الاذربيجاني اما بالنسبه
لارمينيا فطبعا ا خسائر اي اي نوع من
الدعم العيني الذي تقول عنه من تركيا الى
اذربيجان انا انا طبعا اقصد
قبل كل شيء تصريحات تصريحات
داعمه تصريحات الرسميه للمسؤولين في تركيا
داعمه لاذربيجان كذلك لا ننص بان تركيا
تزود اذربيجان بالاسلحه ايضا كان هناك
المعلومات بان بعض المناورات العسكريه
التي حصلت قبل كم صابيه التي شاركت فيها
تركيا واذربيجان تركيا قد تركت كل اصلحها
في اذربيجان ايضا هناك الاخبار عن ارسال
المرتزقه اذا هناك اكثر من دليل بان تركيا
تقف الى الجانب الاذربيجان وكما ذكرت
اذربيجان تشعر هذا الدعم هذا شيء اما
بالنسبه لارمينيا في يعني ارمينيا اصطدمت
مع خسئ على ساحه القتال فطبعا هذا الامر
حيوي بالنسبه للقياده الارمينيه لا تستطيع
هذه القياده ان توافق على تلك الخسائر حتى
باسباب الداخليه الشارع الارميني الشارع
في يريان لن يوافق على مثل تلك
تصرفات لقياده الدوله
فطبعا قد قد تصدم ارمينيا مع المشاكل
الداخليه اذا هناك اكثر من اسباب لاستمرار
هذا الاقتتال ولكن على كل حال هذا لا يعني
بان يجب ان نترك كل امور كما كما هي الان
يجب ان نبض الجهود من اجل ماذا يعني ذلك
لا يجب ان تترك روسيا كل الامور الان على
على ما هي عليه انا انا كما ذكرت اولا نحن
يجب ان نتعامل مع كلا طرفين من اجل اقناعه
ما لجلوس على طوله الحوار على لق لقاف
اطلاق النار وثانيا طبعا انا اعتقد ان هنا
وقد قام بذلك سيرجي لافروف قال بانه اجتمع
نظ نظيريه الارميني والاذربيجانية
به
الطرفان بصراحه هناك عديد من الاساليب
اولا يعني يجب ان يتم نقل هذا الامر من
ايدي الدبلوماسيين الى ايدي العسكريين انا
اقصد يعني يجب ربما ان تكون هناك او ان
يكون هناك اللقاء ما بين وزير الدفاع
الروسي مع نظيريه الارميني واذربيجان ربما
اللقاء المباشر ليس عن طريق الاتصال
الهاتفي هذا الشيء شيء ثاني بامكان رو
تتعاون
وتتعامل مع المواطنين من ارمينيا
واذربيجان موجودين هنا في روسيا يعني انا
تتحدث عن مئات الالف الاشخاص موجودين في
في روسيا هذا شيء والنقطه الاخيره براي
شخصي ولكن حيويه للغايه هو تنسيق مع
الجانب التركي ومحاولات الروسيه لاقناع
الجانب التركي لايقاف هذا الدعم لاذربيجان
بسبب هذا الدعم واضح
وهو يشجع كما ذكرت في سابق يشجع الطرف
الاذربيجان لاستمرار القتال على كل حال
نحن بحاجه الى ايقاف هذا الاقتتال وربما
عن طريق ايضا ارسال بشكل او باخر قوات حفظ
السلام وايضا يمكن ان ندرس الوصفات او
الخيارات الاخرى على كل حال ربما نحن
بحاجه الى اللقاء ما بين وزير الدفاع
الروسي ووزاره الدفاع الارميني و هناك
الكثير من الاوراق وال الخيارات التي تحدث
عنها سيد انتيكوف من روسيا سيد ساكو اريان
ما هي الورقه او الخيار الارجح ان توافق
عليه او تاخذه ارمينيا الان في ظل هذه
الاتهامات هذه الهدنه الهشه وهذا التحقيق
تحقيق التقدم الميداني تتحدث عنه اذربيجان
وهذا النزيف ايضا في الخسائر التي الذي
تتكبده سيدتي فقط ايضا اريد ان اشير ان
الطرف الذي يدافع عن نفسه لن يخرق وقف
اطلاق النار يعني امام وسائل الاعلام
الدوليه والعربيه والاسلاميه الطرف الازري
كما اليوم يتكلم بنفس اللهجه احنا تجاوزنا
هذه النقطه ام تجاوزنا هذه النقطه سيد
اريان يعني تجاوزنا هذه النقطه لا نريد فق
اريد انقط نحن نتحدث عن الخروقات
والاتهامات المتبادله لكن اتحدث الان
نتقدم قليلا نعم تفضل لم ل لم اتهم اقول
الحقيقه
سيدتي اعرف مهنيته تماما واحترمها وال من
الاول ذا بادئ ذ بدء الطرف الارميني يعول
كثيرا على الدور الروسي وكما قال ضيفنا من
موسكو ان الشارع الارميني لن يقبل بهذه
الخسائر يعني نريد حلا جذريا وايضا روسيا
لن تقبل باي خرق وباي لعب
بالمناطق حيا
وايضا
اجبار طرف شعب كارباخ التخلي عن ارضه
التاريخي وايضا ايران لن لن يعني لن تبارك
ابدا نحن نر ماذا يعني ماذا يعني ما قلت
بانكم تولون بان الطرف الارميني يعول على
الدور الروسي اي دور تعول عليه
ريفان يعني يعني هناك حطوط حمر يا زميلتي
هناك حطوط حمر ونحن نعلمها والطرف الروسي
يعلمها جيدا اليوم الولايات المتحده
وفرنسا وموسكو ينددون ب يعني الغطرسه
التركيه والتدخل التركي في هذا الموضوع
اولا على تركيا صحب موسكو لم تتحدث عن اذا
كنت تتحدث عن اتفاقيه التعاون العسكري هي
لا تخور روسيا بالتدخل طالما كان كانت هذه
الهجمات ليس في الاراضي الارمينيه وخارجها
تعود الى اراضي عائده نعم وروسيا
وروسيا س سيدتي وروسيا جهدت جهيد ل لعدم
يعني تكبير المساله وبدء صراع مباشر بين
ارمينيا واذربيجان وهذا مهم وراينا نحن
لدى الطرف التركي ايضا تغييرا في الكلام
ولكن القصه وما فيها ان روسيا تحاول
دبلوماسيا وان لم تقدر على ذلك هناك مجلس
الامن وهناك ايضا يجب اتخاذ قرار بدعوه
جذريه لوقف اطلاق النار وبعد ذلك وسنرى
ايضا كما صرح سياسي
روسي مهم جدا في العاصمه ستيبان جيرد قال
روسيا جاهزه لضمان امن سماء ستيبان جيرت
ماذا يعني هذا سماء ستيبان جيرت مثل سماء
يعني موسكو تماما
لان العمق الاستراتيجي الروسي في قوقاز
مهم جدا وتاريخي وروسيا
ل ليس هناك يعني سنه قانوني
لتدخل سيدتي يوم يوم يوم الجمعه على ما
اظن نسيت اسمه قد
زار ستيبان جيرد والتقى الرئيس ارتساخ
ارايك روتيان وبعد الاجتماع
ادل من اين ينطلق بهذه
التصريحات ب اي
اتفاقيه يعني ا اي لا لا لا حاجه
لاتفاقيات يعني هناك حرب مفتوحه والطرف
الازاري يبيد الشعب الكباخ يجب علينا ان
نتفق بما كيف ننقذ هذا الشعب الامن في
ارضه يعني سؤال غير منطقي على ما اظن هناك
مساله حياه وموت بالنسبه للشعب الارميني
وارخ دخل روسيا اذا الى حد الان اذا كانت
هذه المساله كذلك ا لماذا تاخر تدخل الروس
هنا هناك اعتبارات هناك لان لان الطرف
الارميني لا لم يقل حتى الان انه بحاجه
الى مساعده عسكريه من الطرف الروسي هذا هو
الورد الوضع على الارض والطرف الارميني
يدافع ببساله ويكبد العدو الاذربيجاني
خسائر كبيره نحن لسن يعني فارحين بهذا
الوضع ولكن الطرف الاسيري الذي بدا بهذا
الحرب ولا ولست نحن نعم اذا اذا ارمينيا
هي التي لم تطلب ذلك حتى الساعه تحولوا
اليك سيد اميل عبد اللطيف حتى الان نعم
هناك هناك ايضا سيدتي معاهده تاريخيه بين
ارمينيا ودول الاتحاد السوفيتي السابق
يعني نحن لدينا عده كروت لن نستعملها لحين
يعني اذا اتى الوقت المناسب اوراق اتحول
اليك سيد سيد عبد اللطيف في في باكو يعني
اذا مقابل هذه الاوراق التي تملكها
ارمينيا كانت هناك تصريحات ايضا اليوم
لاردوغان تحدث فيها عن قال بان ثلاثي
مجموعه منسك روسيا الولايات المتحده
وفرنسا تقف الى جانب ارمينيا وتساندها بكل
انواع الاسلحه كيف ستتعامل باكو مع هذه
التصريح هل لديها من اوراق في المقابل
مقابل هذه الاوراق الارمينيه يمكن ان تكون
هذه ورق
تستخدم من قبل
باكو اعتقد انه ما يتعين علينا ان نفهمه
هو ان مجموعه منسك هي للوساطه ولديها
وكاله من الامم المتحده ومنظمه الامن
والتعاون في اوروبا لانفاذ القوانين
الدوليه وبالاضافه الى ذلك التصل الى حلول
لهذه المشكله وبناء على قرارات مجلس الامن
الدولي والقرارات واضحه والقانون الدولي
واضح كذلك اذربيجان هي عضو في الاسره
الدوليه وعضو محترم
وهناك سلامه الاراضي الاذربيجانيه هي مهمه
للغايه ارمينيا تقول انها تدافع عن
اراضيها وهذا غير صحيح البته ويجب ان نفهم
ان اذربيجان هي من يدافع عن اراضيها
وبالتالي نحن نتوقع من مجموعه منسك ان
تلتزم بالقانون الدولي و قرارات الامم
المتحده وتعن عليها ان تقدم الحلول بناء
على وضع حد لتدخل القوات الارمينيه في
ناغورنو كارباخ وبعد ذلك يمكن التوصل الى
اتفاقيات بناءه بين الطرفين بين اذربيجان
وارمينيا وسوف يتضمن ذلك رفاه الشعب
الارميني الموجود في كارباخ ويجب ان نتذكر
ان شعب اذربيجان تم تطهيره عرقيا في
التسعينات من ناورو كارباخ ما من شخص ري
موجود في ناغورنو كارباخ بعد هذه الاباده
وبالتالي نحن لم يكن لدينا اي مشكله مع
المجموعه او الجماعه الارمينيه الموجوده
في مناطقنا
وهناك عدد من الممثلين عن ثقافات اخرى
وبالتالي ان هذا اذا نعم هذا اذا ينقلنا
الى الموقف الروسي الذي يا سيد
انتيكوف هذه التصريحات ما هو موقف روسيا
منها وكيف يمكن ان تتعامل معها تصريحات
اردوغان
باختصار يعني كما ذكرت في السابق يعني
روسيا بحاجه الى استمرار التنسيق مع كلا
الطرفين الجانب الارميني والاذربيجانية
تنسيق يعني كان كان هناك لقاء ما بين
وزراء الخارجيه روسي ارميني واذربيجان هنا
في موسكو ايضا كان هناك الاتصالات
الهاتفيه
ونحن لدينا الامال بان في نهايه المطاف
هذا التنسيق سينجح وكما ذكرت في السابق
ربما يجب ان ننتقل الى المستوى الاخرى وهو
المستوى العسكريين هذا الشيء شيء ثاني كما
ذكرت سابق ايضا هناك ضروره واهميه في
التعاون وتنسيق مع الجانب التركي يعني
تركيا تدرك تماما بان هناك الخطوط الحمراء
موجوده بالنسبه لروسيا ولدى روسيا اليات
لتمارس الضغوطات على انقره نقصد طبعا ادلب
ادلب السوريه والشرق المتوسط وليبيا شكرا
لك من موسكو اندر ايكوف الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي اشكرك من باكو ايميل عبد اللطيف
استاذ العلاقات الدوليه بجامعه باكو وشكرا
لك من نيرفان الكاتب الصحفي ساكو
اريان مفاوضات سد النهضه واتهامات جديده
من ره لاديس بابا بشانها قراءه في سياقها
ودلالاتها مع مريم بالعاليه